[Musique]
votre nouveau livre s'intitule en plein
camp recueil de nouvelles qui s'étale de
1896 à 1996
pourquoi vous avez choisi l'église comme
fondation de votre nouveau à ce que j'ai
cherché un dénominateur commun qui a
fait un siècle de l'histoire qui étaient
là pendant un siècle de l'histoire du
québec
et ma foi du bon dieu j'ai rien trouvé
d'autre que l'église et sa mort je me
suis dit et ben pourquoi pas dans votre
livre vous remercie beaucoup de gens
entre autres de michel oui vous l'a
remercié deux fois plutôt qu'une
pourquoi parce que dominique michel
c'est une petite fille qui est alassane
à thorium et à me raconter certaines
choses qui se sont passées lorsqu'elle
était un sanatorium puis je me suis dit
je voulais parler des sanatoriums jésus
mais toi tu es un ancien et orion clinic
et me dit oui j'ai chaud l'appui à me
raconter des affaires dont je pars pas
vraiment mais entre autres que son
souvenir que c'est que tous les matins
et manger de la soupe
si on veut tuer des techniciens du
service eau il ne manque jamais de saut
alors moi j'en parle pas de ce haut
magistrat vexin bizarre dessous ni
bouzid que bien soupe bien que c'est
vrai que c'est pas vrai je pensais pas
faire de recherche à cet effet mais
alors est un événement qui arrive la
dent dont il me parlait dont je tendrais
pas un métier extrêmement troublant
c'est incroyable que cette chose là ait
pu passer sorte d'amener qui polluent la
nouvelle n ont pas encore sachez que
j'ai hâte de lui lire un petit bout on
sent que les amis la famille ses 13
important dans votre livre dans votre
vie personnelle ou faire le trou sur wii
pour moi c'est extrêmement important
sauf que j'ai pas eu d'enfants les les
fils de coeur que j'élevais étaient les
fils le moment de mon conjoint
je suis grand mère putative tout et
putatif finalement dans cette espèce de
villa et maintenant arrière grand mère
putative et puis ça m'a donné quand même
beaucoup de plaisir mais c'est le grand
regret de ma vie c'est de pas avoir eu
d'enfant puis sauvé c'est irréparable
pas comme aujourd'hui
ah oui pourquoi c'est parce qu'on meurt
sur une question de façon générale quand
on fait une vie normale on a à peu près
la réponse à toutes nos questions
mais la question qu'est ce que j'aurais
fait - il règle l'air de quoi s'il avait
fait une enfant ce sera toujours sans
réponse si triste je trouve sur tristan
ce cas ceux qui ont eu des enfants
comprennent pas ah oui oui c'est
intéressant
oui ceux qui ont eu des enfants
gazométrie franchement ça change pas
grand chose comment ça change pas grand
chose
comme je dis aux faits parlent de vente
qui a été plein tu peux pas comprendre
le vent qui était vide
voyons ça n'a rien à voir quand il a eu
un effet miroir de ces noyaux ça rien à
voir on vous dit parfois montréal
parfois pari qu'est-ce qui lé vrai c'est
vrai le beau oui comment diviser ou
votre heure du temps la difficulté si le
prix de l'avion je traverse à paris où
j'ai quelque chose depuis 1989 traverse
maintenant je suis là en quatre mois et
demi seulement par année je suis à paris
où il fait pas aussi formidable car il
sait la nécessité d'avoir aussi les
lectrices y est touriste à paris ça fait
que vous n'êtes pas mal en attendant
souci quand vous êtes là cela dit c'est
quand même à paris et jade en cd je me
perds dans québec je me perds encore
plus en savoie mais paris j'aime donc
vous écrivez noyau de vue ah oui
absolument
je pars avec mon laptop et j'écris à
paris oui
dans la rue les gens doivent sans aucun
doute encore parler des filles de caleb
sans 1985
quels souvenirs gardez-vous de cette
époque c'est quand même beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de chance ah ouais il
est arrivé au bon moment
un peu grâce à icloud plus que je ne
connais pas et j'avais vu un moment
donné qu'elle avait une émission
littéraire ou et parler de livres une
fois par semaine et tout cela
contrairement à tes grosses secousses
prix piketty mais si les américains ne
sont capables de lire des briques
les québécois en sursis sur moi et c'est
comme ça que les filles de caleb sonné
je vais faire une grosse pic
c'est tellement irrationnelle certains
de manière rationnelle
[Musique]
ça va donner un fond de pension que la
vie m'a jamais donné
c'est simple sécurisé pour richemont
mais je vais me rendre au moins jusqu'à
100 ans dont 90 je promets de mourir à
90,4 la charge de la société va être
costaud merci beaucoup merci
qu'est ce que c'est merci
[Musique]